good morning Hank it's the 2013 project
for awesome huzzah so Hank the 48-hour
project for awesome livestream begins at
noon Eastern Time today there's a link
in the doobly-doo or you can just go to
youtube.com slash log brothers and right
now click right here click click
anywhere to open a new window that will
take you to the project for awesome
fundraising page where you can get
amazing perks like the men of YouTube
calendar the women of YouTube calendar
or a twenty page snippet of the story
I've been working on for the past few
months 100% of the money that we raise
will be distributed to organizations
that we as a community choose by voting
at projectforawesome.com all of these
links are in the doobly-doo so we raise
the money but then we also choose how to
distribute it so it's up to all of us to
be good stewards of the money we raise
okay three final notes you can find
project for awesome videos by searching
YouTube for project for awesome 2013
every comment that you make on a project
for awesome video or tweet with the
hashtag project for awesome is worth a
penny and lastly for the first hundred
twenty-five thousand dollars every
dollar that you donate will be matched
by anonymous donors so your dollar is
worth two dollars alright on to my
project for awesome video so Hank there
is a lot of worldsuck but there are two
absolute humanitarian disasters going on
in the world right now first in the
Central African Republic hundreds of
thousands of people have been displaced
in thousands killed after a coup that
eventually spiraled into sectarian
violence Hank right now there are 40,000
people in and around the airport in the
capital city of bangy trying to get to
food and medical supplies and to safety
schools are closed and growing numbers
of children are being conscripted to
fight in militias and Save the Children
is on the ground they're treating
children who've been injured by machetes
and gunshots and offering basic health
services to kids and their families and
Save the Children is also working in the
countries that border Syria where more
than two million Syrians are now living
in sprawling refugee camps like this one
more than half the residents of these
refugee camps are children okay let's
listen to this woman nor talk about
trying to feed her young son back in
Syria who is shy and is not a Muslim not
in the more I just moved lioness in
Ella's in contracts non-ohmic Lala's
nanana she has a new darkest era we are
political so ain't no aid organization
is gonna fix the disasters in Syria and
the Central African Republic
malnutrition and disease aren't just
caused by lack of access
food and healthcare they're also caused
by war and politics and decaying
infrastructure and the problem is so
complex and overwhelming that sometimes
it feels like you can't do anything that
nothing you do can matter but it does
matter okay here's a kid named Sammy
what kind of you do of the vigilante of
London mama mama Johnny the good news is
that Sammy doesn't have to worry anymore
that his siblings won't be able to eat
that's what organizations like Save the
Children and others in the refugee camps
are fighting to accomplish and it does
matter I truly believe that Sammy and
more than a million kids like him will
be better off if nerdfighteria partners
with effective and efficient
organizations like Save the Children who
are working in these refugee camps heck
Noor is eight months pregnant right now
and if we invest in her baby that kid
will have a better chance of going to
school and leading a healthy life which
we know are two of the biggest
predictors for adult success these
people are worth investing in and while
they may live far away from us they are
still our neighbors and I am convinced
that if we help these kids now they will
eventually help us to live in a more
peaceful and just world so that's why
I'm asking you to go to
projectforawesome.com and vote for Save
the Children and other organizations
that fight poverty and disease in the
developing world Hank again links to
everything below I will see you on the
p4a livestream